if you're failing repeatedly it's
possible that there's something wrong
with the way that you're conceptualizing
the world if you are arrogant to the
point where you do not take feedback
where you blame everybody else where you
just think you're right all the time
ultimately you lose when we are afraid
of failing we come up with a story about
how it's not our fault or how we're
gonna do it in the future people are
overwhelmed so they just they come up
with a story that I tried everything
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message don't be arrogant
over you Jordan B Peterson if you're
failing repeatedly
then there's probably something wrong
it's possible that there's something
wrong with the way that you're
conceptualizing the world because you
have a choice right if if you keep
making sacrifices and they don't work
there's a binary choice and one is well
there's something wrong with the
structure of reality and the other is
there's something wrong with your
approach and so then you might say well
let's take the first idea there's
something wrong with the structure of
reality it's like you're really gonna
say that are you you're really going to
come out and say I know enough to judge
the nature of being and and then the
alternative is also quite frightening
because then you know you it's you
that's making the mistakes and you might
be wrong at a really deep level and that
might mean that a lot of you has to burn
off and be transformed maybe even things
about yourself that you think are
admirable and that you like because your
position you know your your self
conceptualization is so warped and wrong
and that's really daunting but you know
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being I mean I've written about
this a fair bit in my new book which is
called 12 rules for life
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being then they take on what
can only be described as a kind of
satanic arrogance because they've
actually taken to themselves the moral
right to criticize the structure of
existence itself it's like you better be
careful when you do something like that
because you're setting yourself up as
the judge of being I think the
difference between arrogance and
confidence is humbleness if you are
arrogant to the point where you do not
take feedback where you blame everybody
else where you just think you're right
all the time
ultimately you lose and here's the
interesting thing I don't think you lose
necessarily in the market you might
actually win you might be so good at
what you're doing that you don't need to
practice that you don't need to learn
that you don't need to get better you
could still win just because you're so
good at it but what you lose is in what
you could have been you lose compared to
your potential you lose because you're
coasting if you look at the people who
had the most success they are confident
but they're not arrogant you look at
somebody who you might think as Eric and
you look at someone like Kobe Bryant who
comes off as really arrogant and yet
he's the first guy to show up for
practice he's humble enough to come to
practice and be the first one and leave
it all on the floor and say I still need
to practice to get better my jump shot
can still get better
my dunks can still get better I will be
the first one even though I am the best
player here I'm gonna be the first one
to practice I'm gonna practice more than
anybody else that's the humbleness that
leads to confidence that leads to
success this is a great story my book
top ten rules of success Zig Ziglar if
you guys don't know Zig Ziglar legendary
speaker one of my favorites of all time
he talked about it he talked about
preparation here 187 page 187 Zig Ziglar
rule number five be prepared how many of
you feel like I've made this talk before
several hundred times I made it
yesterday you know what I did between
yesterday and today I spent over six
hours getting ready for today you see I
think it would be arrogant if I thought
I could stand up and spit it out just
because I did it yesterday a hundreds of
times that's arrogance that's the
difference and I think for you guys as
practical take home think about this
how much time are you spending learning
and practicing if you spend a good
amount of time every single day
learning to get better and practicing on
your craft even if you have done it
hundreds or thousands of times
are you still spending every day
practicing if you are then your humble
then you had the right to be confident
and you will win if you aren't then
you're arrogant and ultimately you're
cheating yourself
you're cheating your community you're
cheating the planet of the great
contribution that you could make and I
think it's especially hard for the
people who are really talented because
you can win and coast but you can win
even harder if you had a little bit of
humbleness in YouTube and that applies
for athletics entrepreneurship family
everything every aspect of your life you
might be winning but you could win even
harder if you had that humbleness baked
in so you could be confident
instead of arrogant now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know what do you need to
practice more on what have you been
coasting on in your business in your
life you've been good at it but you've
been coasting and you need to practice
practice practice what is that thing
leave in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
I spray so give me go
what do you tell yourself on your worst
always say okay what could I have done
honestly and if you can't do that
honestly you better have someone around
you that can do it was a point of one of
my first films I got so angry with the
director he pulled me up and was kind of
saying some things to me basically you
are doing a bad job and I went home and
I was found a dev I said you know his
director and dad too right she listened
to and she said a Konami honestly then I
said yeah and she goes I don't think
you've done that work I'm doing the
research I'm doing the work of knowing
what you want the scene to be yeah call
me and was I partly right about the
director short but actually the thing I
take away from that was head of going
you could know better how to do
something is the wrong sequence to start
with like what's the strategy for being
fit and healthy it's not that complex
and yet 70% of the u.s. is overweight he
doesn't have to do it it's not a
strategy problem
what it is is why are they doing it it's
because they have a story and everyone
does is entrepreneurs business people
everyone does this when we get fearful
when we've tried something that we're
not succeeding as fast as we want when
we are afraid of failing we come up with
a story about how it's not our fault or
how we're gonna do it in the future
because then we don't have to feel bad
feeling bad makes us have to deal with
it most people are overwhelmed so they
just they come up with a story that I
tried everything
have you tried everything you'd be fit
you know I tried million things millions
name of three things they did any times
that don't work but I think if you can
come up when you change the story when
you come up with a new set of beliefs
you'll find yourself finding the
strategy or using the strategies that
already work that are there that right
now your mind says are won't work and
the best way to change people you got
strategy story is state and I only share
this with disss owners you've got to be
able to produce a different state in
your people there has to be something
compelling there has to be a sense of
mission altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video